well this is your second time at the
Nexus in City
what do you think makes the Institute
special and why do you think it's
important that it exists I think there's
many reasons for that I first and
absolutely first and foremost is it's
hopefully a man who is an absolutely
crucial figure I think in Europe
generally in a moment who one of the
very few people I know that has the
courage to to question things that
nobody actually dares to question and to
say things that nobody dares to say and
raise discussions on subjects which are
absolutely crucial from a point of view
which is not biased but actually
interested in in a true and sincere
exchange on on those Ono's matters and
that's the only way to actually come
forward and and reach any sort of
progress on political cultural and
social themes and I tremendously admire
his work and I think that his his work
basically gives the spirit to the
Institute in many many ways and I think
it's very important to their place which
is not affiliated with a particular
direction but with it just with the
sheer interest of questioning things and
raising and creating such different
situations in contexts where such a
discussion such an exchange can can
happen exists I think very very often
these things happen with a certain
agenda with a certain goal and I think
the most beautiful thing about all Nexus
projects that I've been either involved
with or I've seen that you never know
what's gonna happen it's not there is no
clear goal with it it's the idea is to
bring very very a very diverse group of
people together throw them at each other
and see what happens you know you will
be further than where you start and I
think that's extremely important thank
you for that
what has Nexus meant to you personally
it meant many different things first of
all I will never forget the day when a
few years ago Rob suddenly calls me up
and says well mr. Solomon just cancelled
would you step in and do this this
master class with a with the members of
the consular orchestra on Marler and I
was first of all completely overwhelmed
by that I mean I was I was very very
young and it was a huge responsibility
as well considering first of all the
topic and the fact that somebody saw in
my work
the sort of let's say the true core of
it and it gave me that chance and had
trusted me with that kind of task was
first of all very moving and important
for me personally but also showed me
that there is actual interest in the
kind of discussion I would like to raise
and it's very rare to find people that
are interested or willing to risk to
that extent that just say I don't care
if this person is famous I don't care if
this person is you know has the right
political connections it's about I think
that what this person is doing is right
and it has to be supported and threw me
straight into the you know most I would
say most critical and and and anyway
many ways also sort of dangerous let's
say spot you know and said you know go
do your thing and and knew that it's
going to work out and that is that
courage is something a tremendously
admire and I have in many ways seen it
also as an example to follow in my own
work and and try to promote and
encourage people that I believe in
regardless of where they come from and
what they have already achieved
wonderful my final question this
symposium that we're having right now
it's about building about education what
do you consider essential in any
education I think I could talk for three
hours to a question I'll tell you just
one anecdote which I think will will
summarize the whole thing and when Rob
asked me to write this essay I first of
all wrote on something completely
different from what he asked me to write
and that's what usually happens and but
just out of as a as my very first
initiative was I wanted to look up in
the dictionary when it asaurus and see
what is the definition in a typical
English dictionary of Education and then
it says something along the lines of the
act of teaching somebody something in a
school and I remember I was so shocked
by that sentence basically so the stuff
you learn in school is what a dictionary
sees education that was for me the first
the first impulse to actually question
what is it that we are we are giving or
we are in a way leaving for for the next
generations to have what is what is our
cultural identity what is our how what
is knowledge how do we define
all each other we define is I mean we're
living in times were I think most people
consider information to be knowledge and
that is something that that I think is
profoundly mistaken and and how what is
knowledge have actually become and I've
found the whole the whole occupation
with this with this topic extremely
inspiring to realize that knowledge has
very little to do with facts and with
information and education has also in in
its broader sense very little to do with
knowledge but with an actual form of
identity and on that I could elaborate
at length but I will I'll let you do
that in the symposium thank you very
much thank you
okay now don't smoke
you